we're told a scale on a blueprint
drawing of a house shows that 10
centimeters represents 2 meters what
number of actual meters are represented
by 18 centimeters on the blueprint so
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out so the main thing to
realize is that a blueprint drawing is a
scale drawing of something in the real
world in this case of a house and so
what we could do is set up a little bit
of a table here so let's put the drawing
on the left so this is the blueprint
drawing and then this is the real world
real world on the right and the unit
that we're using the units that we're
using in our drawing are centimeters so
we have centimeters over here and then
in the real world we're thinking in
terms of meters and so let me make a
little bit of a table and so we see that
10 centimeters on the drawing
corresponds to 2 meters in the real
world so 10 centimeters in the drawing
corresponds to 2 meters in the real
world then they ask us what number of
actual meters are represented by 18
centimeters on the blueprint so 18
centimeters on the blueprint would
correspond to what in the real world
well there's several ways to approach it
one way to think about it is look to go
from 10 to 18 we are going to multiply
by 1.8 so to go from what 10 centimeters
represents in the real world to what 18
centimeters represents in the real world
you would similarly multiplied by 1.8 so
times 1.8 which would give us 3.6 3.6
what 3.6 meters in the real world so 3.6
meters in the real world would be what
18 centimeters on the blueprint
represents let's do another example
jaelyn draws a hen with scale of 2 units
on her graph paper represents 6 meters 6
centimeters in the real world the hen is
16 units tall in the drawing
what is the height in centimeters of the
actual hand so once again pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
all right so let's just set up our
tables again so for our table so we have
our drawing and then we have the real
real world and in our drawing is just
these little units on our graph paper so
I'll call it just that units and the
real world we're thinking in terms of
centimeters centimeters and so let me
set up a little bit of a table here and
so we know and we see that right over
here from this scale we can see that two
units represent six centimeters in the
real world so two units in our drawing
represent six centimeters in the real
world and then they say the hand is 16
units tall in the drawing so it's 16
units tall in the drawing
what would that represent in the real
world which would be the actual height
of the hand if two units represent six
centimeters and now we have eight times
as many units well that's going to
represent eight times as many
centimeters so 6 times 8 is 48
centimeters so what is the height in
centimeters of the actual hand
48 centimeters 48 and we're done